The Joe Rogan Experience I think of
marriage is is a certain thing which is
the um
the context for
uh for procreation for the for the the
building of the the nuclear family what
about people that get married that don't
have kids are you opposed to that what
if they get married they decide you know
we don't need kids I'm going to get
fixed you get your tubes tied let's
travel the world
well what do you mean am I opposed to it
I mean I I think that uh that every
married couple should be open to life
but what if they don't want to do are
you opposed to them being married if
marriage is only for procreation and to
bond a family together what about people
that are deeply in love that never want
to have children
I don't think it's it's not only
procreation but that is one of the
fundamental definitional uh
uh aspects of it of course there's more
to marriage just than that and what
about people that are infertile they've
fallen in love and they realize that
they can have babies they don't really
necessarily want to adopt is that okay
for them to be married because then
you're by definition marriage falls into
a completely different thing because
then it's a bond of love it's a union of
love
sure I mean
that doesn't change the nature of of
marriage though it's a little bit like
um I say that uh what's the definition
of a woman well a woman is someone who
by her nature can conceive children in
her womb and their children and then the
response is always what about women who
are infertile does that does that
destroy your definition of woman and it
it doesn't because you know it's still
it's still a woman's nature to Bear
children not every woman will and there
will be disease and infertility and and
old age and all these things that will
preclude that but it's still it's still
of her nature to do so
um and I would say the same thing for
marriage I mean it's it is natural in a
marriage for for procreation to occur
it's not always going to happen in
reality though but that's still
that's still one of the natural
functions of marriage and and uh married
couples who can't conceive children
there are other ways to
um be parents like adoption for example
if they want to right but if people want
to be married and don't want to ever
have children are you opposed to them
being married
well I'm not I'm not I would Advocate a
law that would prevent it but would it
change the definition of what their
marriage is to you because they don't
want to have a family they just want to
have a loving Bond
I think this will be a couple that is
rejecting
one of the fundamental aspects of
marriage and they they should be they
they should be open to to life I would
hope that in the future they would be
but but isn't that just a personal
choice I mean you can have a very
fulfilling life if you just follow your
Pursuits and your dreams and your your
interests and you find someone that
shares those interests with you and you
share time together it's very fulfilling
it's a loving yeah it's a it's a person
it's a personal choice and that I'm not
advocating for like a law that says you
if you're a marriage you have to have
you have to have X number of kids
um but then why are you opposed to two
gay people doing that
well because because again it's it's
it's not about Choice it's about what
this institution marriage is an
institution and what is it and what
purpose does it serve
and I I I do not agree with
um tearing down or or changing this
definition
especially because the people who have
changed the definition haven't come up
with a new one so they say well that's
not what marriage is
so for thousands of years we said
marriage is the procreative Union
and then we had the other side came
along and said well it's not that
okay well then like what is it exactly
and I know you said well it's people who
love each other two people love each
other well but then why two people why
do they have to love each other
um you know all these kinds of questions
you get into what if they're they're in
the same family what if brothers and
sisters want to marry and I know every
time that comes up you know the
advocates for gay marriage will say well
that's a slippery slope argument that's
fallacious but it's actually not it's
like we're trying to get to what do you
even think this institution is now
since you've rejected out what we were
saying it was
and um
and I've never found a a compelling
definition and any definition offered
it's like it's like well what do you
what's even the point then why do we
even need this now
I just don't see how a gay marriage in
any way damages a straight marriage
I don't I don't see it at all it doesn't
make any sense to me it just seems to me
that if people want to be look if you if
you wanted to look at logic
especially in our modern society which
is
pretty [ __ ] when it comes to
relationships it's somewhere in the
neighborhood of 50 of all marriage is in
a divorce anyway
they don't make it you know if I don't
know if anything would damage marriage
and damage the institution of marriage
it's the option of divorce I don't think
gay people and gay people getting
married in any way shape or form changes
a bond that you have with your wife it's
just called marriage it's a human
invented thing if we decide that gay
people can get married too I just don't
see how it damages anything I don't
think it tears down the definition of
marriage in any way it just opens up the
possibility that people who are gay
won't be discriminated against
yeah I don't think that a a gay couple
existing uh directly impacts you know
there's a gay couple and you know
wherever and and I'm with my wife and in
our house like obviously there's not
um but I'm talking about I'm talking
about on the individual level I'll talk
about on this on the societal level
right I would agree that um
divorce especially uh you know uh
there's no fault divorce rampant divorce
I don't think it's as high as 50 I know
that that's the that's often quoted I'm
not sure where that comes from but
um it is high it's like it's too high
and Chris Rock has a great joke about
that and so those are just the people
with the courage to get out it's like
how many cowards stay but it's also it's
also true that the advocates for what we
call now traditional marriage which I
just call marriage but the advocates for
traditional marriage
put themselves at a disadvantage by
allow especially in the churches like
allowing this rampant divorce to occur
um and then you've already
sort of given up on some marriage is
supposed to be monogamous and uh and
permanent as well as procreative
well you've given up monogamy and
permanence and so now it's not that's
that's two of the three legs gone and so
now this assault was waged on the
procreative part of it and it was just
it was it was difficult to withstand it
because the institution had already been
weakened so I agree with you there
um
but my answer to that is to try to
reinforce what marriage is not to just
give up on it
entirely and I I still think
you're left with this question of like
if marriage is not what I'm saying it is
then what why do we even need it what's
the point I mean you're saying it's a
it's a man-made Institution
yeah but you but you're also like the
way that you're presenting it it's it's
also it's a totally meaningless
institution no they don't need it at all
no it's not meaningless because it means
something to the people that get married
so it's just it's just a subjective
symbolic thing I mean what yeah so it's
kind of what it is look there's a
massive responsibility when you're
married and when you have children to
keep your family together and you raise
and keep everybody happy and healthy and
this great reward to that yeah but it
doesn't always work out
it's not it's not a it's people change
people are [ __ ] up that doesn't it
doesn't always work
and so I don't think it should be
outlawed because 50 of the people fall
apart
just like I don't think it has any
effect whatsoever on a straight couple
if a gay couple decides that they want
to make it official and that's what it
is to them it gives them a feeling that
that they're accepted and appreciated
and that they're not discriminated
against because they happen to be
homosexual
so but what you're articulating to me is
the damage that's done
buy gay marriage to the institution of
marriage but how is it done how is that
in any way damage straight people
because
we are making the institution
meaningless but it's not meaningless
it's very meaningful to the people that
have it subjective symbolic and it's
about your own personal feelings isn't
it though
well no I I would say that it's not it's
well if it's not subjective and it's not
symbolic
codifies and protects and uh gives a
name to
a thing that actually exists which is
which are you know man woman couples
creating
people creating creating babies
um but not always
right but again that's that's still the
that's still the nature of the Union so
but what are the percentage of people
today that are married that don't have
children I bet it's pretty high amongst
heterosexuals probably
is there something wrong with that
I think there is something wrong with
that I think it there is something wrong
with
you know getting married and saying or
just we don't We're not gonna have any
kids at all but why is there something
wrong with that if someone's personal
choice
why would that why is it wrong that two
people are like you know I am deeply
committed to work and I don't want to
sacrifice any of my career and I don't
want to ruin a kid because I'm
constantly at the office but that's
where I get deep satisfaction and and
that's that's what I'm focused on and
the woman says that's great because I
don't want children either I really am
attached to my interest in my career and
what I like to do that's not damaging
your relationship with your wife and
your family it's I don't certainly I
certainly don't think of it as a threat
to my marriage or my family yeah it's uh
it is a personal choice right but
shouldn't people be allowed to make
those personal choices like isn't that a
fundamental aspect of what it means to
be American to have that freedom
well right yeah but right now we're not
talking about what people are allowed to
do I'm not saying well we're talking
about marriage gay marriage okay we we
were just discussing straight couples
who treat a couple of students that's
also a personal freedom issue isn't it
yeah but and I'm not saying that that
straight couple should be legally
required to have kids but I you know if
you're asking me do I think it's the
right choice to just get married and
choose not to have kids ever I I do not
think that that's the right choice am I
it's their it's their choice but people
can make choices that are wrong
is it wrong if they have a fulfilling
and wonderful life together with that
choice if their their thing is that they
just want to have a bond between the two
of them to just like take it to the next
level let everybody know like we are
married if I die my money's going to go
to Helen and if Helen dies you know I
you know I'm gonna mourn her because she
was my wife and I'll be a widower like
to some people that distinction gives
them peace and security and makes them
feel better about the relationship that
they're both so committed that they've
legally signed documents that say that
they're Bound by law and under the eyes
of God or whatever you believe in yeah
they're they're able to make that choice
but I think you're rich they're still
rejecting
one of the purposes of marriage
and in the scenario that you just
outlined you're also
deciding to live
a really self-centered life you're
saying what if you're not what if your
work is very charitable what if it
benefits Humanity in a deep way well if
you spend a lot of time doing you know
Health Care work and you know and social
work and you're you're deeply committed
to your community it's not selfish at
all you're just dedicating your time to
something other than raising new human
beings yeah that's dedicating your life
to enhancing other human beings that are
around you that's a hypothetic he's a
hypothetical so is yours right yeah but
I think most of the people that choose
like we're not gonna have kids and and
the the rate of
those rates are declining
um
and
the age when people first have kids is
also going up and all that yeah most of
the people that are making these choices
I don't I don't think it's because
they're involved in charity work I do
think that it is more
the the scenario you outline in the the
first time around which is just like
well this is what I'm doing you know I
have my job I don't want to give it up
yeah
um but don't you think that people
should have the freedom to live their
life in that way I think human beings
vary widely in a huge way and I think
there's some human beings that find a
very fulfilling life just reading books
and traveling and experiencing different
things and seeing art and doing whatever
the [ __ ] they want to do and they don't
necessarily have to have kids to live a
fulfilling life that way and if they
choose to do that with someone who they
have a loving bond with and who they get
married to I don't think it's a bad
thing that they don't want to have kids
well I think
I guess we have to maybe we're running
into a question of of
you know now you get to the real
fundamental question if it's a
fundamental Freedom thing yeah we're not
disagreeing I guess on the Freedom
aspect of it because again I'm not
saying that you should be required to
have kids so you're imposing your
sensibilities and what you think is
important in life to other people but
everybody has a different idea of what's
important without hurting anyone the
thing is like what I'm saying is these
people that are that are married that
don't have children they're not harming
anyone they're not harming these unborn
children that they never have they're
not harming anyone and it doesn't affect
your relationship with your family and
your marriage at all yeah but I'm also
not I'm not imposing myself on them or
harming them by answering a question
about
about how I feel about their choices
right but nor are gay people doing that
to you I think the harm comes from
on a societal level
when we start breaking down these basic
uh Central institutions like the
institution of the family in a marriage
that's where the harm comes from and the
more that people believe the more that
we build a society where it's believed
that marriage is
objectively meaningless right it's it's
entirely subjective it's just about it's
just not making you feel better
um the more that we build a society like
that I think the that's where the harm
comes in the worse it is and people are
going to reject marriage
um and uh and that means more you know
fewer kids are being born also more kids
are being born in a context where they
don't have that stable family structure
so the harm definitely comes it may not
be this immediate you know connect the
dots thing but uh
yeah and when we can already see that